за багаторічною парламентською традицією
завжди тут був прем'єр-міністр Де він
зараз Можливо у нас уже новий
прем'єр-міністр це пані Роксолана
підласа насправді це свідчення того
ставлення до парламенту Кабміну який
подав абсолютно не бюджет воюючої країни
тому що якщо там залишається збільшення
фінансування прокуратури і інших силових
структур Я хочу нагадати що не прокурори
підуть в Контрнаступ тому що якщо там
залишається серіальний Контрнаступ
марафонний Контрнаступ на що ви
виділяєте 440 млн 2 млрд на канал Рада
знову 200 млн якій не показує парламент
і де працюють ведучі з каналу медведчука
у вас там є ганебні абсолютно статті
наступу на децентралізацію що не
відповідає Не тільки бюджету воюючої
країни а і бюджету країни яка іде до
Європейського Союзу адже ЄС - це сильні
регіони у вас там близько 60 млрдв
коштів це гуляючі кошти нічим не
підтверджені тому що ви вже заклали в
цей проект бюджету гроші з військового
ПДФО хоча законопроект ще не прийнятий
відповідний не зафіксований цеє
порушення Конституції і Повірте що ми
будемо звертатись до Конституційного
Суду щодо того як ви нищити
децентралізацію плюючи на наші
зобов'язання щодо вступу до ЄС ви нищите
наші зобов'язання по копенгагенським
критеріям коли закладаєте кошти на
олігархічні телеканали якщо Брюссель
дуже чітко вам сказав боріться з
олігархами а не годуйте їх з руки ви
даєте податки які сплачують в тому числі
військові Кому олігархічним телеканалам
ви знову закладаєте мільярди на
інвестиційні няні замість того щоби
створити рівні правила для всього
бізнесу і це після того як ви повертаєте
перевірки щодо бізнесу Отже звичайно ми
утримаємося щодо цього проекту бюджету
звичайно ми будемо моніторити Як ви
витрачаєте ці кошти І знаєте коли ви
звертаєтеся до заходу з проханням дати
допомогу фінансову Україні то чуєте
відповідь дуже справедлива А що у вас
відбувається з економікою Чому ви не
перебудували за 20 місяців економіку на
військові рейки чому сьогодні і досі ви
не створили ці підприємства які мають
виробляти снаряди Чому ви не закла дате
кошти на фортифікаційні споруди і Мінні
поля поблизу лінії зіткнення багато чому
але відповідь Ось уряду тут немає
міністр фінансів фотографується з
дівчатами Всім весело у всіх знаєте
культурний Контрнаступ в той час коли ми
маємо обговорювати реальні проблеми в
економіці і створювати уряд національної
єдності професіоналів і технократів які
дадуть відповідь на проблеми в економіці
які ви